JLo's this is me now inspired by her
happily ever after with Ben Affleck
today the couple officially hit the half
year of marriage Mark I got a little
update from the pretty and pink newlywed
and her shotgun wedding co-star Josh
dumel what's the best part of this
chapter and and you know being married
to Ben
there's so many things I mean I I
couldn't you don't have enough time
right now let me tell you about my
relationship with this
it's a beautiful streaming he's a
beautiful man he's dreaming it looks so
much better than the rest of us Jennifer
marry me shotgun wedding a real wedding
it really actually feels like you've
been immersed in all things Bride for
like the past years I never expected any
of this to happen in the way that it did
uh so but it's exciting they're very
different and I've never done one like
this
yeah
Josh and Jen's Dream wedding descends
into chaos in the action-packed comedy
streaming on Prime video January 27th I
had to get my inner Lucille Ball on for
this you know what I mean it was kind of
more a high jinxy more kind of Broad and
the action added a whole other element
to it is that blood
me and Josh I mean I I couldn't have
gotten luckier to have the most amazing
leading man who could do the comedy do
the action and really you know nail the
emotional stuff Pirates chasing you
wasn't on your vision board you're the
only thing on my mission I just want to
ask is that genetics or is it like
Pilates your co-star Jennifer Coolidge
she really is having a moment what I'll
never forget about working with Jennifer
was that you didn't know if she was like
messing up on purpose
Everything feels awkward like what just
happened and then you see that is she
intending to be funny yeah she'll be
really lost right now and it makes
everybody feel like wait you need to
know to take she's like no I'm good like
okay I guess and then you see it it is
brilliant nobody with my family
[Music]